hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to the
edition of ask Evan today I'm doing
another one of my fiber gigs where I
review somebody's website and showcase
it on my youtube channel and today we
are going to be reviewing fresh start
CPA calm and so let's check it out so
this is the website is it is an
accounting firm so from first glance
it's easy to tell what they do which is
great a big problem for a lot of
websites and entrepreneur website you
have no idea what they do and if it's
for them or not so for me if I'm looking
for an accountant then I know that these
guys are clearly accounts they are in
where mobile accounting firm parkville
so if I'm in that area then my consider
looking them up phone number at the top
great you know logo is is clean easy to
read website design is is pretty you
know professional I guess what you'd
expect from most professional services
types of companies the one thing that is
missing here so I see a lot of
information I see your services a little
bit about you this notice is the about
slide and it's showing a picture of a
pencil all of the pictures seem to be
very stock photography which is very
common but what I would try to do is
inject a little more personality and
show your picture so who are the people
behind fresh start tax and accounting
now entrepreneurs like to deal with
people as much as possible and so if you
told your story why you got started what
you're all about then that will convince
more entrepreneurs to want to sign up
with your services of everybody else
what's missing from this page
is why you so I would try to address one
of the common frustrations that most
entrepreneurs go through and why they
seek out advice from accountants if you
looking at the very you know startups
it's do I need an accountant or not and
and how can you help me and there's a
lot of Education involved in training
your new entrepreneurs on how to work
with accountants and if you're further
along then it's more about you know
switching them from one account to
another and it's getting them to
understand that you really understand
their business now a big problem with
entrepreneurs in their accountants is
they meet with their accountants once a
year they go over their financial
statements you know and fine I'll see
you next year but the accountant is not
a critical part of their business and if
you are the type of accountant that
really you know care is about declines
and you don't take the time to invest
into understanding their business and
giving them advice beyond just showing
the numbers which saying here's how you
can use this information to grow your
business then that's a value add that
not everybody will do and maybe a way to
separate yourself so what's missing from
the page is it's it's great and that it
tells us what you do how to get in touch
with you you know where you are but it
doesn't tell me why I should go with you
instead of somebody else so if I am
shopping for an accountant it's a little
bit unclear as to why I should go with
you instead of anybody else who's also
in the area um let's click on the about
and see what more information you have
here it talks about yourself so our
values professionalism responsiveness
quality so find out I'd love to learn a
little bit more about the people so okay
good you have a meet our team and so the
toy array great you know you've got a
good picture here smiling not stock
photography I put this more front and
center you know show the people on your
team and and tell the story you know she
fell in love with the county that's
great I tell this to have some of the
entrepreneur she's helped and why she
really likes it maybe there's an
interview with her and put that right on
the homepage
let's see who else you have here d me
ray okay not there Danielle Martin you
know again good smile no picture this
one so at least the ones that you do
have pictures of put that that put that
on the on the homepage and should be
proud of your team you know I think
that's something that if you tell your
story why you got started while your
passion about accounting that's
something that entrepreneurs going to be
able to relate to because they are
really passion about their business and
they want to work with people who are
also equally passionate or what they do
now I did see somewhere on here you know
further there's not too much personality
on this page so you can definitely amp
that up a little bit and it's great that
you're sharing you know information
resources what I like there is a
recommended books and so this is where
we're starting to show a little bit more
of the personality of your organization
because you're sharing stuff on here and
these are books that are not just about
accounting so delivering happiness you
know that's your favorite book visionary
of Virginia serio of Zappos explains how
he Howard emphasis on culture can lead
to unprecedented success that's great
you know these these are great resources
for entrepreneurs and this this list
goes on and on and on and on from the
sidebar here which is awesome and if
you've read all these books and you
personally I Paquette them this is a way
of showing that you care about
entrepreneurs and you care about your
customers and you're showing a little
bit more personality beyond just saying
here's what we do and so somebody who
steps outside of this here's what we do
is more likely to win the hearts and
minds of people and are going to get the
clients so if I had a choice between
going to one accountant who just shared
you know there are services and another
one who shared all these great resources
with these books and why they liked it
I'm probably going to go with the one
who gave me more who showed them chill
took me more of who they were so I try
to inject a little bit more personality
use your pictures a little bit more
showcase this stuff a little bit more
maybe there's other components to it
that you know you really want to share
about yourself and why you started your
business maybe if you do a quick video
and
Joe if you're comfortable in front of a
camera it will really win over people
and if they're trying to decide between
you and somebody else then it makes it
easy to say yes to you maybe one quick
look we'll check out the social media
profiles we've got facebook and twitter
here on the side so let's look at each
see we got so Facebook is just going to
the Facebook homepage so the link is
going to fresh start cpa but looks like
it doesn't work so I'd either you know
look at fixing that link or taking it
down if you don't have a facebook page
you don't want to be linking to it these
people will expect to see something on
there and the Twitter you've got a
Twitter account this is great you're
tweeting out which is great and it's
pretty active and you have some good
information and your retweeting and then
talking to people so that's great as
well it's good to your you're staying
active on here a lot of people set up
these accounts and and they don't do
anything with it so you've been posting
regularly that's great I'd look to
expand that on facebook as well or if
you don't think Facebook is your market
then then just take it off and don't
include it on your on your cipher
anymore but overall it's pretty good you
know you're you're fortunate I guess
you're in a market where you know
typically financial service companies
financial professor professionals if you
look in accountants lawyers are
typically are very bad promoting
themselves and the websites are not
great so it's good that you have a clean
fresh website easy to follow easy to
understand I just try to inject a little
bit more personality into it and
showcase why we should go with you over
somebody else and I think you'd have a
much better response rate than the
people who are visiting your site so if
everybody watching thank you for joining
me on this latest video if you liked it
please give it a thumbs up it makes
going to do more for you and if you have
a comment about this video or question
about your own company feel free to
leave it in the comment section below I
always read those and
love to hear what you have to say so
thank you and I'll see you on the next
episode
you